Im indonesischen Tauchparadies
Raja Ampat
liegt das Dorf Sawinggrai
mit seinen 120 Einwohnern.
Über die Hälfte davon sind Kinder.
Sie besuchen
einen ganz besonderen Unterricht.
Also, wenn wir fischen gehen,
woran müssen wir dann denken?
Nicht auf die Korallen stehen.
- Schnorcheln.
Den Abfall mitnehmen.
Richtig. Damit wir das nicht vergessen,
haben wir unser Memory.
Wer weiss es noch?
Wie viele Fische
sind in der Kategorie grün?
90.
Jonas Müller ist gebürtiger Glarner
und arbeitete früher
als Betriebsökonom.
2014 gab er seine Karriere auf,
lernte Indonesisch
und eröffnete hier sein Lernzentrum
für Umweltschutz und Ökologie.
Wir spielen ein Memory,
das ich selber gemacht habe.
Es ist in drei Gruppen unterteilt:
grün bedeutet,
dass es noch viele Fische hat.
Die Kinder können sie
mit gutem Gewissen essen.
Orange bedeutet,
dass es eher weniger gibt
und sie möglichst
einen anderen Fisch fangen sollen.
Rot heisst,
es gibt den Fisch kaum mehr.
Diesen sollen sie nicht holen.
Saltwater crocodile.
Jonas füllt mit seinem Lernzentrum
eine Lücke,
denn das Niveau der
staatlichen Schulen ist sehr tief.
Hier dagegen lernen die Kinder
spielerisch und nachhaltig.
Es hat diverse Lerneffekte.
Einerseits sollen sie ihre eigene
Sprache aufrechterhalten können.
Das Spiel ist in Englisch
und in der einheimischen Sprache.
So lernen sie einerseits
die englischen Namen der Fische,
was wichtig ist für den Tourismus.
Sie lernen die Namen aber weiterhin
auch in ihrer einheimischen Sprache
und auch, welche Fische
sie im Meer holen können.
One. - Two. - Three. - Four. - Five.
- Six. - Seven. - Eight.
Am Mittag setzen die Kinder
das Gelernte in die Tat um.
Speerfischen
steht heute auf dem Programm.
Weil der Platz auf Jonas' Boot
beschränkt ist,
müssen die Jüngeren zurückbleiben.
Ein Boot ist für meisten Bewohner
hier unerschwinglich.
Umso grösser
ist die Freude der Kinder,
wenn sie mit Jonas
aufs Meer hinausfahren dürfen.
* Entspannte Musik *
Jonas Müller lebt in Indonesien
in Südostasien.
Bei West-Papua
liegt das Tauchparadies Raja Ampat.
Etwas abseits und vom Tourismus
noch weitgehend verschont,
findet sich das Dorf Sawinggrai.
Hier hat Jonas Müller
seine Umweltschule eröffnet.
Ich interessierte mich bereits in
der Schweiz sehr für Umweltthemen.
Als ich aber hierherkam und die
unglaubliche Schönheit der Natur,
aber auch die ganzen Gefahren sah,
wurde das Bedürfnis, mich zu
engagieren, noch viel stärker.
So ist es nach und nach entstanden.
Die Kinder haben inzwischen gelernt,
dass ihre Ernährung
von einem intakten Ökosystem abhängt.
Denn Fisch ist ihre tägliche Nahrung.
Stopp!
Kinder, schwimmt nur in der Gruppe!
Arno, zuhören!
Wir gehen da rüber speerfischen.
Und schiesst nie
in die Richtung eurer Freunde!
Die Kinder sind jetzt immer zu zweit.
Sie müssen sich
an ihrem Freund orientieren.
Zum Glück haben wir zurzeit
kaum Strömung, was gut ist.
Hier in Raja Ampat haben wir
eine der stärksten Strömungen weltweit.
Aber jetzt sind wir ziemlich bei peak high.
D.h. fast keine Strömung,
was eigentlich sehr gut ist.
* Entspannte Musik *
Wasser ist auch die Welt  von Adelrich Uhr -
schon von Berufs wegen.
Er ist Klärwerksmeister der Abwasser-
reinigungsanlage Küsnacht-Erlenbach.
Auch privat ist Wasser seine Passion.
Heute will er
nach verschollenen Schätzen tauchen.
Ich packe mein Tauchmaterial für
den heutigen Tauchgang zum Wrack,
das wir im April  bei Stäfa gefunden haben.
Es ist der 23. Tauchgang,
den wir heute absolvieren.
Wir erhoffen uns
natürlich noch weitere Funde.
Das ist die zweite Lampe, die wir
auf dem Wrack gefunden haben.
Das ist eine Backbord-Lampe.
Ausserdem haben wir einen
Ringschlüssel aus dem Motorenraum.
Dann haben wir einen Schuh gefunden,
der unter dem Schlamm vergraben war.
Wir holten ihn dann hervor.
Wir vermuten, dass der Schuh
von einem Matrosen stammt,
der auf dem Schiff war und mit ihm unterging.
Wir suchen die Geschichte immer noch
in der Dokumentation der "Zürichsee
Zeitung" und im "NZZ"-Archiv.
Aber wir haben bis heute nichts gefunden.
Aber der 58-jährige Hobbyarchäologe
gibt nicht auf.
Obwohl er schon über 300 Std.
im Archiv verbracht hat -
zusammen mit seinen Kollegen
vom Tauchclub Swiss Archeodivers.
Adelrich Uhr  wird von allen nur Agi genannt.
Sein Tauchclub  ist ein exklusiver Zirkel.
Nur wer einen Kurs in
Unterwasserarchäologie bestanden hat,
wird als Mitglied aufgenommen.
Hoi, Agi.
- Michi! - Tschau. Hoi.
Hoi, Roli.  - Morgen, Agi.
Alles klar - Alles gut.
Tschau, Adrian. - Geht's dir gut?
- Röbeli. Beno. - Hoi.
Hört mal her,  es gibt eine Besprechung.
Wir waren jetzt 22-mal unter Wasser.
Auf den ersten drei bis vier Tauchgängen
konnten wir Relikte heraufholen.
Heute gibt es eine Abräumaktion.
Markus und ich gehen zuerst runter
und messen erneut den Motorraum aus.
Dann werden wir
einen Teil des Schuhs suchen,
der noch irgendwo dort unten rumliegt.
In 20 Min. sind alle komplett
ausgerüstet auf dem Schiff.
Ist das für alle realistisch?
- Ja. - Auf dem Schiff?
Die Hobbyforscher  untersuchen das Wrack
mit der Einwilligung
der Zürcher Kantonsarchäologie.
Dafür wird alles genau dokumentiert.
Vor der Abfahrt
steigt die Spannung der Hobbytaucher.
Du bist wirklich wie ein kleiner Lausbub,
der sucht, macht und tut.
Plötzlich hörst du, dass da etwas ist.
Dann suchst du.
Und dann findest du etwas.
Schatzsuche - ein Bubentraum!
Man kann es nicht anders sagen.
Kann das Team dem See
noch mehr Geheimnisse entlocken?
Gibt das Wrack
auch den zweiten Matrosenschuh frei?
(Jonas) One, two, three, go!
* Sanfte Musik *
Die Unterwasserwelt von Raja Ampat
ist paradiesisch.
Allein während eines Tauchgangs
erwarten einen bis zu 300 Fischarten.
Welche Fische gefangen
und welche verschont bleiben sollen,
können die Kinder
nun unter Beweis stellen.
Dieser Junge
hat einen Soldatenfisch erwischt.
* Sanfte Musik *
Die Technik des Speerfischens
mit einem einfachen Gummiband
lernen die Buben schon von klein auf.
* Sanfte Musik *
(Jonas) On the front!
* Sie sprechen indonesisch. *
Oft haben wir
eine Machete auf dem Schiff.
Damit schlagen wir dem Fisch auf den Kopf,
falls er noch lebt.
Dann ist er auch tot.
Ich habe ihnen gesagt,
dass sie das machen sollen.
Sie haben keinen Bezug zum Tier,
es würde ihnen nie leid tun,
es könnte noch so zappeln.
Ich bin aber dafür, es möglichst
schnell von den Qualen zu erlösen.
Jonas verwendet grösseres Geschütz:
eine selbstgemachte Harpune.
* Sanfte Musik *
Auch für ihn gilt die Regel,
nur so viel zu fischen,
wie er auf einmal essen kann.
* Sanfte Musik *
* Prusten *
Es ist ein Kaninchenfisch.
Man muss sehr gut aufpassen,
weil  die Stacheln des Fischs giftig sind.
Das Gift ist zwar nicht tödlich,
aber wenn das jetzt
an meinen Finger gelangen würde,
wäre dieser 30 Min. gelähmt.
Und bis am Abend
würde es sicher ziemlich schmerzen.
Mit diesen Fischen
muss man relativ vorsichtig sein.
Einen Stachel zu berühren,
der ein leichtes Gift enthält,
passiert sehr oft -
vermutlich fast wöchentlich.
Die schlimmste Verletzung war,
als ich auf einen Blauring-Oktopus trat.
Es ist eines der giftigsten Tiere
der Welt.
Er biss mich in den Zeh. Innerhalb
von 2 Min. war ich komplett gelähmt.
Das Gift ist in 99 % der Fälle tödlich.
Ich hatte Glück, dass die Einheimischen
sehr schnell reagierten
mit Feuer und ihren Blättern etc.
Wobei alle westlichen Ärzte sagen,
das habe nichts gebracht.
Aber es gibt weltweit kein Gegengift
für Tetrodotoxin.
Die Behandlung, die sie gemacht haben,
kann nicht falsch gewesen sein,
denn ich habe ja überlebt.
Ich musste mir
einen Zeh amputieren lassen,
da er sich
irgendwann aufzulösen begann.
Ich liess ihn mir
in der Schweiz amputieren.
In der Schweiz bleiben
wollte er deshalb aber nicht.
Zu wichtig sind ihm
die Kinder von Raja Ampat.
In Bern liegt noch der letzte Schnee.
Nach einem Apéro ist Ornella Weideli
mit ihren Freundinnen unterwegs
zu ihren Eltern.
Hallo!
- Hello!
Hallo zusammen.
- Cooles Plakat!
Nicht wahr?
Mein kleines Mäuschen.
So, hallo!
- Haben wir's auch noch geschafft.
Welcome home! Ciao bella.
Die letzten sieben Monate schrieb Or-
nella in Miami an ihrer Doktorarbeit.
Es geht direkt los.
- Wo ist das Öl?
Auf der Durchreise zu den Seychellen
ist sie auf Blitzbesuch  in der Schweiz.
Was hast du gesagt, Käthle, drei?
Wir haben jetzt natürlich kein Fleisch.
Einige Leute legen noch etwas Fleisch
auf diesen Grill. - Nein!
Da die Mehrheit Vegetarier ist ...
- Nein, nur Käthle und ich.
Eben.
Und wir sind gemässigte Flexitarier.
Guten Appetit. Ornella, santé.
Guten Appetit, danke.
Auf dich!
- Prost.
Ich vergesse manchmal, dass ich
gerade sieben Monate weg war
und so viel erlebt habe.
Es ist spannend, so eine Tochter zu haben.
Sie ist nicht oft da,
aber es ist spannend, wirklich.
Es macht Spass.
Die Versuche des Vaters,
den  Freiheitsdrang der Tochter zu zügeln,
sind kläglich gescheitert.
Ich versuchte das ein bisschen,
mit Nachdruck:
"Wir wäre es so mit Lehrerberuf?"
"Biologielehrerin am Gymnasium in Bern,
am ehrenwerten Kirchenfeld-Gymnasium?"
"Das wäre doch ein Traum."
Der Eigennutz wäre: Sie wäre hier bei uns.
Vergebens.
Denn nach dem Biologiestudium zog es
Ornella nicht in die Schulstube,
sondern in die Weltmeere -
als Haiforscherin.
Schon als Kind träumte sie sich
in Unterwasserwelten.
Das sind
einige meiner lustigen Erinnerungen,
die ich schon ziemlich lange
nicht mehr angeschaut habe.
Ich muss sie selber kurz durchsehen.
Es sind Zeichnungen
der letzten 25 Jahre, nehme ich an.
Das. Das ist das actionreichste.
Es war alles immer meeresbezogen.
Datum hat es keins.
Evtl. mit zehn Jahren?
Man sieht Fische,
die einander fressen,
die einander auflauern.
Einer, der sich versteckt,
einer, der einen anderen frisst.
Die mögen sich.
Dieser ist auf der Jagd.
Diese tanzen.
Ja, ziemlich lustig.
Ich weiss, ich ging immer reiten.
Pferde sind auch sehr dominant.
Aber in jedem Pferdebild ist ein
Orca, der im Hintergrund springt.
Also, das ist auch irgendwie ...
Ich glaube,
das war wirklich mein Traum.
Hier ist die etwas neuere
Kollektion, nach den Zeichnungen.
Ich habe von vielen Orten,
die ich besuchte, etwas mitgenommen.
Zwei Haigebisse,
die ich selber säuberte.
Sie stammen von toten Haien,
die wir gefunden haben.
Wir haben sie stundenlang gesäubert.
Das sind meine kleinen Schätze,
die ich hier aufstelle,
da ich kein Daheim habe. Deshalb
stehen sie bei meinen Eltern rum.
Aber ich betrachte sie immer wieder,
wenn ich hier bin.
Auf dem Zürichsee bei Stäfa
sind Agi Uhr und sein Team gespannt,
was der Tauchgang zum versunkenen
Wrack ans Tageslicht bringen wird.
Agis Tauchbuddy Markus Inglin
macht Unterwasseraufnahmen,
um das Wrack zu dokumentieren.
Der Rest des Teams folgt später nach.
So wird
möglichst wenig Schlick aufgewirbelt.
Dann, in 22 m Tiefe, taucht es auf:
das Wrack des Ledischiffes,
über 100 Jahre alt,
gefertigt aus massivem Tannenholz.
Auf seiner letzten Fahrt um 1910
transportierte das Schiff Sand.
Agi und sein Team fanden heraus,
dass es mit dem Heck voran versank.
Die Wucht
riss das Dach des Motorenraumes weg.
Was hat das Schiff zum Kentern  gebracht?
Ein Sturm? Ein Leck?
Agi vermisst den Motorenraum
und findet einen kleinen Gegenstand.
Der gelernte Maschinenmechaniker
ist überrascht.
Es ist wunderschön!
Es ist unglaublich!
Es ist so lange nur blau-blau.
Und plötzlich
kommt das hier aus dem Nichts.
Nach 13 Flugstunden
ist Ornella Weideli beinahe am Ziel.
Eine kleine Insel im Indischen Ozean.
Es ist jedes Mal wieder anders.
Ich fliege zum neunten Mal drüber.
Es haut einen jedes Mal wieder um.
Diese Farben, man sieht,
wie das Wasser reinkommt.
Die kleinen Inselchen.
Dort ist ein ganz kleines.
Es hat nur einige Sträucher drauf.
Wenn wir Glück haben,
sehen wir unten noch Mantas.
Die Landebahn
ist nicht einmal 1 km lang -
und für den Piloten
eine Herausforderung.
Unfassbar!
Hello!
- Hi, how are you?
Ornella erwartet ein warmer Empfang
der Forscherkollegen
und Bewohner der Insel.
Die 32-Jährige
hat hier über mehrere Jahre
das Leben von Junghaien untersucht.
Good to see you. How are things?
- Very good, thank you.
* Sanfte Musik *
Mitten im Indischen Ozean
liegen die Seychellen.
Sie bestehen aus 115 Inseln.
Eine davon ist D'Arros.
Ganz in der Nähe
liegt das Saint-Joseph-Atoll,
wo viele junge Haie leben.
Ah, endlich wieder warme Luft.
Das ist Downtown D'Arros.
Man kann es am Verkehr erkennen.
Hier ist das Labor, die Wäscherei,
dort hinten lebt der Island manager.
Jetzt sind wir
bereits am Ende des Dorfes.
Jetzt gehen wir
zu unserer Unterkunft.
Sie liegt schön zwischen Palmen.
Wenn wir Glück haben,
sehen wir Landschildkröten.
Da ist eine.
Ah, es ist so schön! Es ist immer
wie ein Nachhausekommen.
Es ist,
als wäre ich gar nie weggewesen.
Und doch sind seit ihrem letzten
Besuch acht Monate vergangen.
Wunderbar, vielen Dank fürs Fahren.
- Gerne.
Very nice!
Sie sind alle oben
und trocknen sich die Flügel.
* Ruhige Musik *
Wie immer zieht es die Haiforscherin
gleich als Erstes zum Meer.
2009 sah ich
auf den Bahamas den ersten Hai.
Einen kleinen Zitronenhai.
Ich glaube, an Tag 2
schwammen wir bereits mit Haien.
Und ich fand: "Wow, das ist es!"
Herrlich, herrlich!
A ghost crab.
Ein Geisterkrebs, nehme ich an?
Davon hat es ganz viele.
Sie sind relativ schnell.
Das Feriengefühl  ist von kurzer Dauer.
Bereits morgen steht eine Exkursion
zu den Junghaien an.
* Ruhige Musik *
(Jonas) Okay.
Speerfischen ist anstrengend.
Die Kinder sind hungrig.
Kakak, grosser Bruder,
ich warte dort drüben.
Papa,
soll ich das Boot hier festmachen?
Es kommt lustigerweise häufig vor,
dass sie mich "Mama"
oder "Papa" rufen - aus Versehen.
Sie merken es aber sofort.
Ich glaube schon, dass ich
für viele Kinder eine Vaterfigur
oder evtl. ein älterer Bruder bin.
In den Familien in dieser Kultur
ist das Kind einfach da.
Natürlich hat es auch ein Daheim,
aber es ist nicht wie in der
Schweiz, wo man nach Hause geht,
mit der Familie zusammensitzt
oder etwas zusammen isst.
Hier wird in dem Haus gegessen,
wo es gerade genügend Reis oder Fisch hat.
Das muss nicht im eigenen Haus sein.
Ich glaube, dass ihnen so
oft eine Bezugsperson fehlt,
die sie dann in mir finden.
Die Jungen jagen die Fische,
die Mädchen nehmen sie aus.
Die Geschlechterrollen
sind hier traditionell verteilt
und nie würde ein Kind
einem Erwachsenen widersprechen.
Schade, sie sind klein,
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8.
Was ist das Problem,
wenn wir kleine Fische fangen?
Die konnten sich noch nicht vermehren.
Genau, und dann haben wir hier
irgendwann keine Fische mehr.
Wir müssen also Geduld haben,
bis wir sie essen.
* Sie sprechen indonesisch. *
Das Gute ist, dass alles Fische
aus dem grünen Bereich sind. Super!
Es sind aber diverse Fische dabei,
die eigentlich zu klein sind.
Und doch: ein Erfolg für Jonas.
Denn früher war das ganz anders.
Überall auf die Korallen gestanden,
alles, das sich schnappen liess,
haben sie rausgeholt.
Vorher haben sie eine Schildkröte
gesehen, die hätten sie auch geholt.
Aber mittlerweile wissen sie auch,
dass die Schildkröte einerseits
sehr wichtig für das Riff
und andererseits ein Touristenmagnet ist.
Jetzt holen sie sie nur noch
für grosse Feste. Sonst nicht mehr.
* Entspannte Musik *
In der Schweiz
ernährte sich Jonas vegan.
Hier lebt der 28-Jährige wie die Ein-
heimischen von Fisch, Reis und Eiern.
Tagein, tagaus.
Grundsätzlich hat man Anrecht auf den Fisch,
den man selber geschossen hat.
Wenn man mehr als einen hat,
teilt man.
Selbst wenn sie nur einen hätten,
würden sie ihn teilen.
Es ist sehr schön zu sehen und es
spricht auch sehr für diese Kinder,
dass alle ruhig hier sitzen
und alle Fisch essen.
* Sie sprechen indonesisch. *
Doch bald ist es mit der Ruhe vorbei.
* Fröhliches indonesisches Lied *
Bei diesem Spiel müssen sie herausfinden,
welches Tier jemand ist.
Sie singen:
"Welches Tier bin ich?"
Sie machen entsprechende Bewegungen
und die anderen müssen antworten.
Noch das letzte Make-up.
Okay, ready?
Sie geben einander natürlich nie recht.
Wenn die eine Gruppe eigentlich
recht hat, sagen sie: "Nein, nein!"
Okay, one, two, three!
* Schreien und Lachen *
* Ruhige Musik *
* Jubelruf *
Das ist die Zündkerze!
Wie es aussieht, ist es ein Vierzylindermotor.
Schon ein grösserer.
Also, ich kann noch nicht sagen,
ob er ein Petrol oder Benzin ist.
Aber sicher ein starker Motor,
der später eingebaut wurde.
Es ist geil, haben wir das gefunden.
Das ist ein wichtiges Indiz.
Agi weiss jetzt  mit einiger Sicherheit,
dass das Schiff
erst nach 1910 gesunken ist.
So? Hätten wir das.
Super! Hast du die Kerze gesehen?
- Ja.
Die ist wirklich von einem Vierzylinder.
Es kommt jetzt nach über 100 Jahren
zum ersten Mal an die Oberfläche.
Mal schauen, was dran ist.
Agis Tauchkollegen schicken
weitere Fundgegenstände herauf -
mit dem Segen der Kantonsarchäologie.
Das sind Sachen aus dem Motorenraum.
Das ist ein Teil des Kamins,
den wir heute noch bargen.
Wie das genau funktioniert,
weiss ich auch nicht.
Es ist ein schweres Teil.
Aber es stammt vom Kamin.
Dann haben wir hier ...
... auch einen Teil des Kamins.
Wir wollen die Russpartikel abkratzen
und auch schauen, was es ist.
Da war wieder so ein Silch
von einem Fischer dran.
Ich weiss von ca. 15 Wracks,
darunter ziemlich grosse.
Ich lese ja die alten Zeitungen
von 1845 bis 1900.
Ich suche dort nach Einträgen
von versunkenen Schiffen.
Dort liest man immer wieder über Schiffer,
die besoffen herumrasten.
Das war ein Lohnbestandteil, Alkohol.
Und die waren
wirklich auch stark alkoholisiert.
Wahrscheinlich konnten sie
nur schon deshalb nicht schwimmen.
Wenn mal einer ausrutschte, sank er
mit seinen vollgesogenen Kleidern.
* Unverständlicher Funkspruch *
Das Projekt ist abgeschlossen.
Aber alle wissen:
Tief auf dem Seegrund warten
noch viele weitere Geheimnisse.
Priis!
- Priis!
Haiforscherin Ornella Weideli
hat den vielleicht schönsten
Arbeitsweg der Welt.
Auf der Seychelleninsel D'Arros
leben gerade mal 30 Menschen.
Einst war sie französische Kolonie,
später im Besitz der ehemals
reichsten Frau Frankreichs:
Liliane Bettencourt.
Heute betreibt die Schweizer Stiftung
Save Our Seas
hier ein Forschungslabor - finanziert
von einem saudischen Mäzen.
Ornella bereitet die Exkursion vor.
Hinter ihr ein imposanter Schädel
eines Pottwals,
den es einst angespült hat.
Kannst du mir helfen?
So ein Durcheinander!
Ryan Daly ist der lokale wissen-
schaftliche Direktor der Stiftung.
Er unterstützt Ornella
auf der Expedition.
Könntest du
den anderen Haken befestigen?
Er liegt dort
beim Kabelbinder und der Schere.
Haie zu sehen und mit ihnen
zu schwimmen, ist das eine.
Das macht extrem Spass. Tauchen
und Schnorcheln ist das Schönste.
Aber es macht auch grossen Spass,
sie zu fangen, von Nahem zu sehen
und sie zu spüren. Mit ihnen
zu interagieren ist übertrieben.
Aber sie ausmessen und
genauer anschauen, das macht Spass.
Ihr Ziel ist das Saint-Joseph-Atoll,
das von D'Arros
20 Bootsminuten entfernt ist.
Vom Atoll trennt sie
ein 70 m tiefer Kanal.
Was sehr speziell ist in einem Atoll
und allgemein in seichten Gewässern,
ist, dass sich das Wasser
tagsüber extrem aufwärmt.
Wir sind hier am Äquator.
Die Sonne kommt von zuoberst runter,
von der Mitte des Himmels.
Das heizt das Wasser natürlich extrem auf.
Auch jetzt.
Es sind heute ca. 30 °C.
Man kann sich vorstellen, wie heiss es wird.
Hier, wo wir jetzt durchfahren,
ist der einzige Eingang ins Atoll,
wo wir mit dem Boot reinkommen.
Hier wird es ganz flach.
Wir sehen es gleich.
Hier wechselt es.
Wenn wir schneller fahren würden,
wäre der Motor zu weit unten.
Ryan muss jetzt gut aufpassen.
Hier sieht man Korallenköpfe,
die aus dem Wasser ragen, coral bommies.
Ryan muss aufpassen,
dass er nicht in so einen reinfährt.
Aber er ist bereits so oft hier reingefahren ...
Dort ist etwas!
Eine Schildkröte.
Nein, ah ja, there you go.
Two!
Da sind wieder
zwei, drei, vier Schildkröten.
Auch ein Stachelrochen zeigt sich.
Very low. - Hm?
- Very low. - Yeah, it is.
Hier vorne haben wir manchmal Glück
mit den Haien.
Wir schauen dort, ob wir einige finden.
Aber es ist momentan noch sehr, sehr flach.
Wir haben herausgefunden, dass sie
bei nicht sehr hoher Flut hier sind.
Einfach aus Beobachtungen.
Manchmal kann man sie,
wenn man von oben schaut,
bereits sehen.
Einer ...
Ryan hat einen jungen Hai entdeckt.
Er kann es kaum erwarten
und versucht,
den Junghai von Hand zu fangen.
Ja!
Yeah, we'll get him.
Man kann sie ziemlich schnell auspowern.
Yeah!
Gut gemacht.
Ist er neu?
Ja, ein Zitronenhai.
Noch nicht gechippt.
Toll!
Ein Männchen.
* Ruhige Musik *
In West-Papua
bricht ein neuer Tag an.
Jonas Müller macht heute frei.
Er will alleine tauchen gehen.
Dazu ist er in den letzten Jahren
nur selten gekommen.
Ich kam 2014 zum ersten Mal hierher.
Nach einem Job bei einer
Umweltorganisation in der Schweiz
suchte ich
nach einem tollen Ort zum Tauchen.
Dann fand ich Raja Ampat.
Ich kam hierher
und habe mich relativ schnell
in die Natur, die Menschen
und das Leben hier verliebt.
Das Tauchen hat mich hierhergebracht.
Das ist natürlich eine Passion,
die ich heute noch habe, das Tauchen.
* Entspannte Musik *
Raja Ampat hat
die grösste Biodiversität der Welt.
Egal, wo auf der Welt man
ins Meer reinspringen würde -
dieser Ort ist unvergleichlich.
Go!
* Sphärische Musik *
Über 1'400 verschiedene Fischarten
tummeln sich hier.
Es ist eine andere Welt.
Magisch und ruhig.
Mittlerweile ist es natürlich das Coolste,
hier in Raja Ampat
als Tauchguide zu arbeiten.
Entsprechend sind die Kinder
auch immer begeistert.
Ich habe sie vereinzelt
als Belohnung mitgenommen,
damit sie ein paar Meter
runtergehen können
und lernen,
mit dem Regulator zu atmen.
Es ist das Beste für diese Region,
wenn die Leute selber
als Tauchguides fungieren können.
Doch das Unterwasserparadies
ist gefährdet.
In der nächsten Folge erleben wir,
wie Jonas und die Kinder
von Raja Ampat diese Wasserwelten
zu schützen versuchen.
Gleiches macht Agi Uhr in der Limmat.
Traurig, dass alles reingeworfen wird.
Und auch Ornella
will mit ihrer Forschung
den Lebensraum der Junghaie
auf den Seychellen bewahren.